clay um
have you seen steph play with or show
that amount of emotion before and uh
what did you see from how he took over
this game
i think i have seen him show that much
emotion and the heart on that man is
incredible uh
you know the things he does uh we kind
of take for granted from time to time
but
to go out there and put us on his back
and
i mean we got to help him out on monday
so we
but um wow just uh
just showed why he is uh
shocking he wasn't a first a first-team
nba guy but whatever
next year
you said sometimes maybe you take what
stuff does for granted you played a lot
of finals games next to him where would
you kind of put this in his
finals performance the resume yeah i
think probably number one i mean this
was nearly a must win game and
to go out there and shoot as efficiently
as he did and
oh and grab 10 rebounds and
and they're attacking him on defense i
mean his conditioning is second to none
in this league
so we are
steph played incredible